Hey Youtubers it's Charlie thank you everyone
that submitted questions on my game of thrones
videos this week, the big news right now is
the Kit Harington just signed up to do a big
movie this summer with Carice Van Houten with
Melisandre they're going to make a shadow
baby together it's actually called brimstone
it stars Dakota Fanning it it's like a big
genre movie but it but it will be a blockbuster
for those that are worried that this might
mean that neither of them will be in game
of thrones season 6. don't worry about it
game of thrones is filming all the way through
the rest of the year like all way up to December
what's likely to happen is that they'll just
be in a little bit of game of thrones season
six that they have to follow up on the finale
anyway but as we learned with Bran storyline
that they can put characters to the side for
a while even if they're big characters and then
bring them back later so Bran will be back,
less of Jon Snow and Melisandre and that's
to say nothing of what Jon snows final fate
is. Really the surprise the announcement is
is that Carice Van Houten is doing the movie
too, so she might not be in as many game of
thrones episodes... but on to questions. Careful
for spoilers if you haven't finished season
five yet. So here we go, first question fleek asks
fleek it rhymes with Reek "I'm new to GoT so
here's my question for the Q&A: does the Red
God and the Many-faced God ever cross paths?
If so, are they enemies or allies?". I know there's
a lot of people that wonder if some of the
gods are really just different aspects of
the same God, particularly the Many-faced God.
I think that for the most part the bigger
deities that we see in the song of ice and
fire are different, so the Many-faced God is
someone different from the Red God, is different
from the Great Other. The Great Other for those
that don't remember is the God of the White
Walkers. The reason he's called that is because
sometimes the white walkers are called the
others, so naturally being a god he'd be the
greatest other. As much as George RR Martin
makes up the plot as he goes along
I-I think he has a pretty strong idea of how
he views deities... It's one of those things
that he declines to answer in discreet terms.
So if you want to believe that they're all
the same God, there's technically no way
to disprove that right now so it's still
open to interpretation... and I don't think that
they're enemies or allies. I think that they're
just two different interests, I don't
think they care about each other... like Jaqen
Hagar said: "It's all the same to the Many-faced god"
Next question, Joey P asks: "Could it be
that there's some warging involved? Maybe Kit doesn't
come back as Jon, but as a new actor?" Nah, I mean,
I think that they would stick with Kit Harington,
if they brought him back... or if he warged
into an animal. I know that they recast other actors
on the show, even big ones, like they recasted
the mountain three times but that was more
for practical purposes, like they just
wanted like a hulking monstrosity.  But let's
just talk about warging for a second, the show
hasn't really explained it, but all of the
Stark children are wargs... it's just that Bran
is the only one that understands how that
works and I mean he's really a greenseer
so that's like an extra added level. They talk
about wolf dreams in the books, those are
Warg dreams. They're like, they're seeing
through their direwolves eyes... So any of the
Stark children that have direwolves, that are
still alive, would still have wolf dreams.
Next question, Lenny asks do you think that
Cersei even cares or thinks about Tyrion
at the moment she has so many other problems
I think she kinda forgot about him. No I don't think that Cersei will ever forget about
Tyrion. She will find a way to blame him for
all of her problems. When Robert Strong was
carrying Cersei off at the end of this season
she was full of hate for a lot of people, particularly
the faith of the seven. You can see it in her
eyes there, she's got like her own Arya list
of names that she's just going to work her
way down. Let's try to guess who is at the
top of her list. Let's guess like the top three
so we'll say : Tyrion, Margaery Tyrell and the
High Sparrow. Next question, Top Shelf asks : "Who
gets Dragonstone now that house Baratheon
is gone?" I would say that'd be something that the
crown would decide, or the small council...
like Kevan Lannister would probably pick someone.
Typically the next person in the line of succession
is the one that gets appointed prince of Dragonstone
like the title, it's like Prince Charles
being prince of Wales. Tommen doesn't have
a cousin anymore and there aren't any Baratheons
that we know about that they could pass it
on to, so it'd either pass to a Baratheon cousin
or they would give it to one of the Tyrells
as a way to get them out of the way. But I
would just expect Kevan Lannister, as head
of the small council, to make that call. Next
question, Drew asks : "If Jon is dead is there a
POV character at the wall to continue the story
there?" Well you know, technically Bran and Davos
are POV characters but they'd have to change of
bunch of book things to make that work. It's just
that those characters in the books aren't
anywhere near the wall, Bran is way north with
the three eyed raven Davos is still in the
north but he's south of the wall. There is some
Melisandre POV in "Dance with Dragons" but I
don't think that she's a POV character in
"Winds of Winter", at least I'm not sure yet, they haven't
confirmed like all the final POV characters yet.
Next question, Caitlin asks : "How, in your opinion,
will the Night's Watch react when they meet
the white army?" So you're talking about the white walkers...
Well they'll all poop their pants and then turn
tail and run. Alliser Thorne is a tough son
of a bitch, so he probably wouldn't run but
he wouldn't be able to defend against them. Half
of the remaining brothers would definitely
take off, the other half would try and fail
to fight them to keep them from coming through
the wall. Just going into theory crafting territory,
what I'm really hoping to see is that the
White Walker army arrives at the wall and
the Night's King finds a way to bring the
wall down. It's implied in the books that there's
an enchantment keeping them from passing through
the wall, like you know otherwise a long
time ago they would've just climbed over... So
they have to have a way to bring down the
enchantments in addition to bringing down
the giant wall of ice. It would be such a bummer
if they just blasted through the gate and
walked through... I mean 700 foot wall of ice,
most powerful magics in the world, why wouldn't
you try to bring the wall down? That'd
be just like the biggest IMAX episode they
could do ever. Next question, Joanne asks : "Heard
about the season 6 script leak? Check it
out!" I know what you're talking about
it's not a script it's actually an audition
that leaked. There was a woman that was auditioning
for the Red priestess that they're trying
to cast for next season, for the Eastern
storyline. One of the directors said that they
have about six episodes written already, so it
could be actual dialogue that we would see
in season 6... The biggest take away is that
you know, of all the characters that people
are wondering : "Are the alive? Are they dead?"
Just excluding Jon Snow it implies that one
of those people, is actually dead. When I say
excluding Jon Snow, like, it's not Jon Snow
related. The same thing happened last year
with the Tyene Sand scene with Bronn where
she likes takes her clothes off and gives him
the antidote to the poison. That leaked, people
thought it might be fake, but then it turned
up word for word in the episode... so this might
be the same thing so just, caution for spoilers.
I'm not going to read the dialogue here... but
the only real take away that that I took from
it is like : "Oh, X character is probably really
dead". Next question, Alezander asks : "If they
bring Jon back to life do you think they would
name him a Stark? I want to see him hold on
to the throne of the seven kingdoms, I think
he is the best character to be king." I'm sure
you and whole lot of other people... No, I think
that he would stick with the same name although
the wildlings and like the other people would
just be like WTF, they might call him something else.
Think about what happened to Daenerys
after she hatched the dragon eggs, she went
from being Daenerys Stormborn to Daenerys, mother of dragons. So if they bring Jon back,
it might be something like that, a
name like that. The only people on the show
right now that could legitimize him would
be the Lord of his House, the Lord of Winterfell
(current Lord), The King : Tommen Baratheon
or Daenerys if she took over westeros if
she was able to take the Iron Throne and became
the true Queen. The only thing that Tommen can do
that nobody else can, is free him from his
vows to the nights watch. Stannis Baratheon
was temporarily a king during the war of the
five kings so that's why he said that
he would do that for Jon, free him of his vows
and name him a Stark. That's kind of a technicality...
Really, Tommen Baratheon is the only one that
could do that. Next question, Chris asks : "Do you
think that The Hound could ever come back to
fight Robert Strong?" Well I mean, there a lot
of clues from the books uh...which I'm not
gonna explain here just in case you haven't read
the books. But I mean, yes it's possible but
I think at this point it would be kinda obvious.
The fan theory is called "Cleganebowl", most of
you probably know what that is, it's just you know Clegane versus
Clegane... in my mind it's in like R+L=J
territory of fan theories, it's just like, people
think that it's all but confirmed. There is
a new character that they're casting for next
season that's tied up in that plot, but I don't
know if they're going to bind him to the gravedigger.
For the most part I wouldn't expect it, if
it does end up happening, you can pop bottles
and pour champagne all over each others. Next
question, Gustav asks : "If they were to change
something about Robert's rebellion in the
"Tower of joy" flashback, what you think it is?"
So you're saying like if they do a "Tower of joy" flashback,
say with like Sir Arthur Dayne and Lyanna
Stark, h-how would they do it? I'll actually
present an alternate theory that I think is
kind of interesting that the flashback, if
we do get Ser Arthur Dayne, won't be to the
Tower of joy... it'll be Jaime's flashback and he'll
be flashing back to his encounter with the
Smiling Knight. He fought this really infamous
outlaw called the Smiling Knight, Ser Arthur
Dayne was there and ended up saving him, defeating
the Smiling Knight. It's just another event from
history involving Ser Arthur Dayne in another
big character from the show, and most of the
flashbacks, on the show, tend to be for characters
that are still alive. So I mean we'll see
how it goes. Thank you so much for submitting
questions for the Q&A this week everyone, these are
always a ton of fun to do. We're almost at comic-con,
they've announced the cast that they're bringing.
Kit Harrington is not on that list, so just
fueling fan theories "he hasn't cut his hair yet"
Unless there's like some crazy casting news
or anything like that, my next bonus video
is gonna to be for the Tyrells, it's gonna
be like a history of Highgarden and the transition
from the Gardeners to the Tyrells, you know, back
after the war of conquests... so be sure to subscribe
to get that. I'll be doing a new round of the
giveaway, it'll probably post on sunday.
Congratulations to this week's giveaway winner
Ross Bauer you won an Amazon gift card, just be
sure to private message me on my channel so
I can get your contact info. I don't know what
the full schedule's gonna be for comic con,
once they post that I'll do a special video
saying what I'm gonna be doing. Probably be
doing panel videos and trailers just
like last year so there'll be like, a bunch of
extra stuff the week of comic-con. For those asking
about a meet up though, I will be doing a meet
up. I don't know which day it's going to be on, I'm just,
I'm waiting for that final schedule the
post so then i'll announce it. I don't have
any merch or anything like that to giveaway,
in future years what I'll probably do is
I'll bring like special prints or T-shirts
just, like, stuff to give to people. In case
you guys missed it, I posted some Arkham
Knight gameplay yesterday. I have my twitch
channel up and working again, I just I change
some of my audio setup so I might be doing
more twitch streaming... I'll probably try this weekend.
If you don't know where the link for that
is, there's one in the description. All the videogame
stuff I do though, that I'll post to my Charlie
streams bonus channel. I don't really intend
to post a lot of gameplay videos to this channel
or anything like that. In case you haven't
seen it yet I posted casting video for a bunch
of characters that they're looking for for
season 6, you can click here to learn all
about them and you can click here for that
Arkham Knight video. Thank you so much for
watching everybody, let's high five and I'll
see you guys tonight!